crystal is in Atlanta hi crystal how are
you I'm great how are you
better than I deserve what's up I am
calling you because I'm trying to
determine whether I should file
bankruptcy or not hmm this is the first
time I've ever heard anything like this
I grew up in a household where all we
did was thin since being my mom for
credit card to credit card so I have no
earthly idea what you're doing even
existed so no listen to you on my phone
and on YouTube and wherever else I can
find it I have two sons a 22 year old
he's diagnosed with schizophrenia and I
have a son is 25 that was shot two years
ago and he's disabled so I wanted to
stop working so that I could stay home
and take care of them in the case they
have doctor's appointments and stuff
right now I'm trying to do that and work
I do own my own daycare center I owned
it for 50 years I do it home take care
and I'll make about $42,000 a year doing
that in the meantime I have a 2014 Kia
Sedona that I'm $10,000 of side down and
because I traded it for a car that was I
bought it brand new
I had another car that was having
problems with the steering column so I
had to trade it and of course I ended up
owing more on the car and what it's
worth it's worth $9,000 22,000 on the
car I also have thirteen thousand
dollars in credit card debt which came
from when I was my son I got shocked if
I had to fly to Arizona because where he
was and now we're trying to take that
debt off and I have a house why did it
cost $13,000 to fly to Arizona well the
credit card has some other debt on it as
well but it ended up you know I had to
buy the ticket like solvent or dollars
go in there and 500 coming back because
you know it was an emergency so I put it
on a credit card dollars it's not 13,000
okay well well there's some other debt
on there but
mainly it was other stuff okay correct
and so so you have 13,000 dollars in
credit card debt $22,000 on the car what
else correct and they don't have a house
but I'm in the process of a divorce and
my husband won't refinance the house so
right now I've got that on my credit and
I'm trying to get that done as well too
because I've been out of the house for
two years now and he hasn't done so and
I'll have money to pay the attorney to
keep me I've given the attorney $3,500
and that's on a credit card as well to
try to get them to get my name cleared
so that you know and I'm paying $1,300
and written for an apartment because I
can't get my name clear but I have
excellent credit so right now I'm trying
to figure out what would bankruptcy do
for you well what it would do is it will
clear my credit so that I don't have so
that the money that only has 13 thousand
dollars in credit card debt
I'm paying $400 a month on the credit
card and five hundred dollars a month on
the PIA so I felt like it was free up oh
so you're going to give up the car - yes
I'm giving up the car so like that was
freed up $1,000 a month because the plan
is as I said is to start working in two
years and stay home and take care of my
boys and then then how are you going to
when you stop working I'm going to
probably do something part-time but the
plan now is to put aside as much money
as I can so that financially independent
in two years well I may not be
financially independent
but meaning I'm right now have enough
money to eat well I have nothing now
either so it's kind of like I guess I'm
thinking ahead of time that I can get a
cheaper apartment there's a reason that
I'm in the apartment now is because I
work out at the apartment I do it you
know I'm big here but I'm doing it in an
apartment right now and I wanted to buy
another house but again I can't buy
another house until I get my name off of
the other one so the main thing in the
whole ordeal I think is that I want to
get my name off the house and the only
way I know to do it is to file
bankruptcy which means you won't be able
to buy another house for four years
which my mom you know I wasn't going to
rent and you know take it from there
doesn't rent something cheaper because I
move out it's you know out into the
another area I would hate to see you
file bankruptcy on this small amount of
that it doesn't really move you along I
think you're just scared and beat up and
you just don't have that much debt I
mean 20,000 $20,000 changes your whole
life and and so what can we do to get
your income up for a short period of
time get your expenses down and let's
begin let's cut up these credit cards
and let's work on a plan together I
don't know this car is a ridiculous mess
even if even if you just toss them the
keys on the car and tell them to come
get it a repossession there's a lot
lighter on your credit than a bankruptcy
is okay and you know even if you just
gave up the car and I'm not sure that I
wouldn't do that I think I would do a
little bit more gathering of information
who told you it's worth 9 I pulled it up
on County Blue Book for a private sale
or trade in it was a private sale okay
so yeah you really are in a mess and if
you owe 22 on something worth then
that's a deep hole yeah so what I would
do is I'm gonna put you on a budget I
want you to go through our class
Financial Peace University I'm gonna pay
for it
okay okay and and let's get you in the
class and get things started cut up the
credit cards and get on a real tight
budget see what we can do to get your
income up and then let's systematically
attack first thing I would do before I
file bankruptcy is try to turn the
corner on this without doing anything
okay the second thing before I file
bankruptcy
I would voluntarily repo the car okay
but I wouldn't do that till I tried it
for four five six months let's see if
you can turn this around without doing
that because that's going to create all
kinds of other messes in your life and
then the third thing you know you may
end up being forced into bankruptcy at
some point but bankruptcy is not a myth
to build wealth and you need some money
for your long-term goal and the best way
to get you the shortest direction to get
you to money's just to clear this debt
off and then to get that mortgage out of
your name and then that sets you up for
you know being able to slow down and you
know I have built some money saved up in
order to slow down and take care of the
boys and so forth so hold on and Kelly
will pick up and she'll get you signed
up for Financial Peace University and
then the other thing is Kelly I'm going
to be in Atlanta this weekend and I'm
trying to remember I can't think of the
name of the church and so just let's get
her invited to that as well I'll be
speaking in Atlanta this weekend I'm
gonna get that in front of me and
announce it anyway so I'll get that
straightened out in a few minutes here
but I'll be down there speaking and so
come down and see us there we're going
to give you a Financial Peace University
and see if you can work your way through
this and if you need some more help you
call me back that's why I'm here it's
what we are doing here